mesdames messieurs bonsoir violents
incidents je vous le disais à l'instant
violents incidents en fin d'après midi
au parc d'attractions de mirapolis une
cinquantaine de forains venus manifester
contre ce qu'ils estiment être une
concurrence déloyale une cinquantaine de
forains donc se sont heurtés au service
d'ordre du parc d'attractions leur ont
apparemment été violent puisqu'il y a eu
plusieurs blessés dont certains seraient
des blessés graves
il semble qu'il y ait aussi pas mal de
dégâts du côté des installations des
renforts de police et des renforts de
gendarmerie ont été envoyés sur place
j'espère que nous pourrons avoir des
images et des précisions supplémentaires
avant la fin de ce journal
bien sûr je vous le donnerai et je vous
indiquerai toute nouvelle information
concernant ces incidents qui se sont
déroulés je vous le rappelle il y a à
peu près deux heures
amira police ces incidents c'était la
fin de journée car jusqu'à 15 heures
environ tout était absolument calme
amira police qui ouvrait ses portes pour
la toute première fois au public un
public venu d'ailleurs assez nombreux
malgré le temps maussade le vent et le
froid
grands et petits avaient testé manèges
et attractions tout à la curiosité de
cette découverte le reportage de
véronique or justement un petit peu
qu'est ce que vous attendez
mira police a démarré en fanfare cet
après-midi des centaines d'enfants
assiste à la parade
quand le voyage de fin d'année coïncide
avec l'ouverture de mirapolis on en
profite pour voir pour toucher à
l'honneur ce matin une heure après
l'ouverture
le cap du millier de visiteurs et déjà
franchi les adultes ne sont pas en reste
premier visiteur première faute au
premier regard envieux patients on se
souvient de votre tour et les tours
aujourd'hui dure autant que des enfants
le demande
voilà c'est reparti premier visiteur
premières impressions dis moi c'était
comment ah c'était super les adultes ne
sont pas les derniers à s'enthousiasmer
je trouve que gargantua c'est très
chouette la ville disent aussi c'est
très bien c'est très beau c'est
impressionnant c'est formidable et je
pense qu'il ya de tout pour l'écran et
pour les petits vous êtes venus avec des
enfants ou sans enfant sans enfants que
des adultes
oui pourquoi pour voir on fait payer de
famille c'est un petit peu premier
visiteur premier repas bien sûr moi
c'est l'euphorie parce que c'est tout
nouveau pour eux et puis bon c'est des
très petits quand même c'est très très
jeune alors il faut beaucoup de patience
et une organisation de feu
et d'abord le grand géant lille était
bien perdre on tue un jeu qui s'était
gargantua oui c'est grand c'est là
qu'est ce que tu vas revenir à mandera
maman une maman qui n'a pas fini
d'entendre parler de gargantua ce soir
pardon du grand géant